se les llama brujas en este campamento
en qq o al norte de ghana viven 113
mujeres en una prisión a cielo abierto
tras ser acusadas de brujería fueron
desterradas de la sociedad apartadas de
sus familias sin recursos
para esta mujer asia fusión y el
infierno comenzó hace seis meses cuando
algunos hombres rodearon su casa la
acusaron de haber matado a una vecina de
su pueblo usando brujería
[Aplausos]
hoy que se reunía una multitud frente a
mi casa y entonces alguien asomó la
cabeza por encima del muro y dijo una
mujer murió y es tu culpa tú la mataste
y vamos a matarte le respondí pero como
pude haberla matado ni siquiera la
conozco
para salvar su vida aceptó marcharse y
venir a vivir a este campamento
nunca pensé que me pasaría que un día me
acusarían de brujería y que me enviarían
aquí ni siquiera creo en la brujería
a menudo estas mujeres son condenadas
por el jefe de la aldea más no por un
juicio a vivir recluidas en estas chozas
a veces con sus hijos y no hay ninguna
ley que lo prohíba
dos ong intentan ayudar a estas varias
mustafa y se trabaja para una de ellas
el mismo pasó toda su infancia en este
campamento
y mama fue acusada de ser bruja cuando
vine aquí crecí me di cuenta que mi mamá
era inocente casi todas las mujeres
traídas aquí están en la misma situación
que ella y mamá ya no está pero me
compadezco de las mujeres que están
acusadas de brujería
hoy visita a la mujer más anciana del
campamento lleva 33 años esperando su
libertad
todos
hola buenas tardes cómo están
su sobrino que le debía dinero la acusó
de brujería para no tener que pagar su
deuda ahora ella pide ayuda para poder
volver a casa por fin
aquí se sufre demasiado ni siquiera
podemos encontrar comida
miren esta red servida con eso hasta
mañana karate que amor como puede
tratarlo a uno la vida cuando la gente
lo rechaza entre la vida y la muerte
apuntó agua van atadas
mostafa recopila información sobre la
anciana para luego defender su caso en
su antiguo pueblo y así lograr que pueda
volver parte del trabajo del defensor es
ir a las comunidades de la región para
cambiar la manera de pensar de la gente
aquí la brujería afecta principalmente a
las mujeres es una forma de eliminarlas
cuando se vuelven molestas por una u
otra razón
era una pareja si las cosas no funcionan
la mujer acabará siendo acosada de
brujería no nadie aquí puede jurar que
una mujer no acabará en un campo a menos
que detengamos estas tonterías pero el
75% de la población de ghana cree en la
brujería la tarea es difícil
sospechan que las brujas le fallaron a
la comunidad así que no están dispuestos
a aceptarlas de nuevo y ha pedido al
pasado entre otros lugares logramos
traer 50 de ellas de vuelta a casa pero
es difícil porque es la primera vez
ghana es oficialmente el último país del
mundo en tener estos campamentos de
brujas en 2014 a una comisión nacional
se le dio la tarea de cerrarlas pero
esto chocó con las creencias locales y
fracasó en la actualidad quedan cinco
campamentos en todo el país que albergan
a 300 mujeres